- léo ferré je suis pas vous avez été
parfait en main intéressé par le passage
où toi nous raconte sa vie j'ai dans
l'est dans les pensionnats dans les
écoles religieuses mais ça ressemble
beaucoup à ce que j'avais tu voyais ça
ressemble beaucoup
oui ça a été battue comme sa part battu
ces issues du petit coup de règle quoi
moi j'ai été lâche chez les frères un
peu de temps nous ont pas battus on a
battu beaucoup à l'école laïque parcours
j'ai moi-même quand j'ai été instituteur
je ne suis pas privé de distribuer des
coups de pied aux fesses amuser les
aliments non gardé beaucoup de
reconnaissance au général a beau vous
êtes pour l'été le jour où je me suis
pas posé la question à cette époque là
on se posait pas de questions mais on
suivait un cours en vue tels que les
enfants qui reçoivent étalages se pose
la question aujourd'hui mars à la halle
se passait par oran la non ce projet
absolument pas de question et là vous
êtes vous posé la question vous apporter
les baguettes
vous savez est ce que vous étiez en
avance sur votre époque
pas du tout non c'est un coup quoi jeter
un con parce qu'on se révoltaient pas à
ce moment là maintenant les jeunes ils
sont et se laisse pas faire et ils ont
raison
moi je me souviens d'une chose et ça
m'avait frappé puis au pr mondiaux on
prend on prend l'habitude n'est ce pas
je me suis je vais bouger un peu pour
vous faire voir parce que j'aime bien
faire les gestes invasifs jeune homme de
théâtre sur le dic au dortoir vous
couchez manger à 19h45 des soir à 8h30
il a été touché
alors comment je fais une connerie
ferrer alors ça est ce que voulait dire
au lieu de me coucher je faisais comme
ça regardez
et les yeux fermés et le mec qui
venaient parce qu'elle est petite
loupiote lot comprenait alors sa frappe
même je vais
et puis il y avait dans votre dans le
livre de fenouil âme il est inapte et
leur le branleur inférieur c'est mon la
marge brute qui m'est arrivé aussi à
cela près que les gestes ce type
ressemblait plus pour voir si vous
laissez des douanes et à de la culture
physique qu'à une gérance précises sur
les parties honteuses les parties
honteuses fait qu'ils croyaient honteuse
c'était un frère qui devait se confesser
et il me faisait faire de la gymnastique
et moi je savais bien que c'est pas la
gymnastique
comprenez et j'y allais quand même à et
pour pourquoi et pourquoi pas ce que
l'âme des enfants c'est pas toujours pur
ce pivot comme ça
c'est moi les choses j'ai dit et quand
il faut se mettre à table je me mets à
table
voilà il se tenait de ma part j'avais 10
ans et ça m'avait frappé j'ai retrouvé
cette annonce air dans le livre de
vannes où c'est pour ça que ça m'a fait
plaisir d'être estime t-on